[Music]
let's shift to Israel for a little bit
that does something to the Jews right a
little bit been in it so so I know you
can make many arguments and I'd be happy
for you to lay them out you know
religious arguments for the reasons that
Israel should exist as a state I think
you can make many secular argument I do
take as much sense historical sense
right that has nothing to do with God
giving this group of people this ayah
grand all right well let's start there
then because I thought you were going to
go more on the religious side so let's
talk about historically I just think
historically here's a people that you
know that inhabited that land that had
that land always wished to return to
that land that was forcibly exiled from
that land and return to it so there's my
grab that up fitting a rap day exactly
all right so when people say whoa wait a
minute the Palestinians lived there now
I know we can I sort of do we want to do
this I we do this for the next hours
apart just do a couple minutes okay so
the universal self before here's a
couple minutes one of the things that
people don't realize is there never was
an independent state ever in that area
yeah after Israel was destroyed
thousands of years ago there wasn't a
Palestine it was always part of a bigger
Empire it was never a separate country
until 1948 when it became Israel ago
meaning it was part of the Ottoman it
was part of the Ottoman Empire was part
of the Roman Empire it was always part
of someone's empire it was never a
separate state if you come to a place
and also there is the reality that in a
throughout history when people have come
to a place and they built it up and
they've made it their own it's become
their own now a lot of origins of States
are lost to prehistory we don't know how
France became France I assure you if we
did it would involve war and conquest as
the beginning of every state inevitably
does the question now is les the origin
of it than the disposition of it that is
how is it that you accommodate the
different people who live in that land
in a way that makes it possible to have
peace I don't think that it is too much
in a world that has 48 Muslim states to
have a Jewish one and I don't think that
most of the world thinks that it's too
much so we when the UN focus
so much on Israel and so much of the
media is constantly attacking Israel and
so much of what I see is from the modern
left not really from the right anymore
maybe rather than to right where it
depends we're going early through it
through an American right through an
American land yes
this endless focus on Israel this place
fits the size of New Jersey right that
is one Airport right that at one point
without the West Bank is about six miles
wide it's absurdly tiny what is that
focus that just that chosen people thing
again so I think that it's a lot of
different things is there an element of
anti-semitism unquestionably I mean
anybody who denies that is being
ridiculous of course there is it's also
the fact that don't forget the Jews are
still the the origin of Christianity is
Judaism and and Christians and Jews had
this sibling rivalry that got enshrined
unfortunately in the New Testament
because you know the family quarrels are
sometimes the most bitter so that that
always the existence of Jews in Israel
always has a special meet met today a
much better one but for a long time a
very negative one to Christians and and
and that venom continued on even in
people who left Christianity
unfortunately and then in the Muslim
world the the confluence of a political
and and a clearly anti-semitic ideology
made it you know made it basically so
that Israel had almost nowhere to turn
and the UN is just a moral swamp it's
just immoral see I mean when North Korea
you know I mean when when Libya is on
the Human Rights Council and whether it
is running women exactly it's just a
moral swamp it's such a I look I've done
some work with the UN and I just want to
say for the record there are things in
the UN that do really wonderful work
around the world but as an institution
it's you want to throw your hands up and
say really this is the best that
humanity can come up with yeah well
certainly not the best event now in love
with but right yet yet here we are here
we are that focus though that sort of
focus and it's
you said there has to be a piece of
anti-semitism related to the I sort of
relentless onslaught I always find
there's an interesting situation with
the Christians that I think you sort of
alluded to maybe it used to be that
rivalry but now if you look at
evangelicals Network for Israel and
Christian sport in general I bet you
that statistically it's probably higher
than Jewish in the milk I can say I know
I've had that experience that I've gone
on trips to Israel at times when there's
been like an Intifada or whatever
the only other groups that are there
Christian groups Jewish groups aren't
there and you say to yourself this is
this is an extraordinary really an
extraordinary phenomenon and the amount
of genuine goodwill in the let's just
talk about America now in the American
Christian community the right America
Christian can be on sorry about the
right wing now because because that's
what Brit evangelicals almost all are
not all but almost ola is extraordinary
it's really extraordinary look I I mean
I've had this experience I this
experience is enshrined in one of my
books one of my books that book called
why faith matters the preface was
written by Rick Warren now the idea that
an evangelical minister would write a
preface to a rabbis book about faith
about today that's just that's a that's
a different world let me tell you a
beautiful story I had a I had a
professor wonderful man named Eleazar
[ __ ] Vic and and he came from Eastern
Europe and and he learned when you
healer when you go by a church you spit
that was what he was taught as a child
because they all want to kill you that's
what he learned all this family went
through camps he escaped but he went to
a labor camp lot of his family died in
Holocaust he comes to the United States
he starts teaching at the University of
Judaism now called the American Jewish
University there's an interfaith
conference in Berkeley and the president
of the University tells him Eleazar I
want you to go and he says I'm Michael
no way I'm going interfaith campuses no
way I'm going to sit there with
Christians and and but he's an immigrant
he's new and the president says you got
to go so he goes the opening meal the
minister who's leading the meal says I
would like to begin this meal the way
our Lord Jesus Christ would have begun
the meal Barakat Adonai
heyno melech ha'olam hamotzi Lechem min
Haaretz which is the Hebrew blessing
over bread and Eliezer said he started
to cry he didn't know that the world
could be as different as it was when he
was growing up and and that's what it is
to leave now and to live in America in
an odd twisted they serve all shellfish
because that I would have met that I
don't know I don't know but but good of
you that all right so the Interfaith in
you mentioned is that an odd place for a
rabbi to be because there's nothing
about converting other people in Judaism
right you're not look well yes I know
no you're not looking I mean there is
something about there before Constantine
and before was made a capital crime Jews
did convert people who not who were
monotheists but who are non monotheists
so an interfaith thing that was not
really a conversion it's an opportunity
for people to talk about their beliefs
and you can certainly learn from other
religious traditions I don't believe and
I don't think that anyone should believe
that Judaism has a monopoly on truth
I've learned a lot from Christian
ministers I've learned a lot from
dialogue with Muslims so I think that
that's a good thing with Hindu I've had
gurus at the synagogue it's had the
Dalai Lama at the synagogue I think
that's a good thing
right right so I'm not saying you
specifically but just generally the idea
that Jews are looking to proselytize
know now that it's so that it's a little
different so that you do an interpreting
where I got a third you and the third
Christians and a third Muslims well the
Christians and the Muslims would love to
have those use convert right or I mean
that is it they would they certainly
yeah that well that is a fundamental
difference not all Christians not all
Muslims feel that way but yeah
Jews basically feel they said it stated
several times in the Talmud that
whatever the world to come is the
righteous of all nations have a place in
the world to come so I don't have I
don't need to save your soul because if
you're a good enough person you're saved
because Judaism believes that it's how
you act in this world that makes the
difference it's not whether you believe
X Y or Z so yeah we don't have the same
motivation we have a motivation towards
good
is more than we do a motivation towards
a specific belief so let's talk about
the afterlife a little bit okay I'm all
in favor of it yeah I am a big fan
people be a little big fan of the
afterlife
I can tell you do watch Gary Busey and a
little Larry to it but there's no that
well there's no heaven in Hell right
well not exactly I mean there is a
Judaism tends not to define exactly what
happens to you after you die
and and that makes sense because as soon
as you start to define it starts to
sound ridiculous
Mark Twain has a passage in letters from
earth where he says people think they're
going to list sly on green fields and
listen to harp music
he says they wouldn't want to do it for
five minutes while they're alive they
think they'll be happy for the rest of
eternity doing it after they die what I
would say that Judaism says is that
human there's something about the human
being that is eternal and just as you
could not have anticipated this world
before you came into it you never would
have imagined like bricks and eyes and
tuna fish and ideas and words I mean who
would have imagined you can't possibly
imagine what another world is like but
there is one so does that change the
ability for doubt the ability I guess
the actions that you take as a rabbi
like everything in Judaism that I know
is sort of about life it's like it's
here it's now right is this kind of
thing well I do not when I like that I
like that's why I think it's so
important here because you don't want to
be you don't want to act here like a as
again as put in the Talmud like a
servant for a reward you're not doing
this so you get that if you do then
religious life has no meaning the whole
point is to do it because you think it's
worth doing right that's what goodness
is goodness isn't being good so that you
get a reward goodness is being good
because you believe in goodness right
hopefully just for the for its ounce a
actual right right so when you
conceptualize God I mean is it a
conscious being I mean is God watching
us right now if God have YouTube I mean
what do we talk about you um I think God
doesn't need you to but I don't mean to
dampen your your note
gigantic audience but um so the way I
put it to the high school kids is I say
look to a 14 year old I said remember
imagine when - year old can a two year
old imagine what a 14 year old is like
no not only can you not a two year old
can I can't imagine it they can't even
imagine what it is that they're not able
to grasp we are in Jewish reckoning the
distance between us and God is
infinitely greater than the distance
between a two year old in the 14 year
old so I don't begin to know what God's
like and I wouldn't begin to say yeah
God's listening to us which is a very
anthropomorphic conception of God all I
do believe is that you can live your
life in a way that is in conformity with
the way you were intended to live or
less so that's what I know
so there are moment so I think in some
ways I put a greater emphasis on
godliness than I do on God that is the
way that I believe God wants us once in
quotes because again once as a human
thing wants us to act without worrying
too much about what God is like because
I know that I'm incapable of beginning
to understand that could you do all that
without God you could the question that
I always wonder is does that stick not
for a life I mean there's there could be
a theists who are kinder than any
religious believer I know a lot of good
atheists I'm sure you do too the
question is as a society does that get
transmitted generation to generation if
you don't believe that there's an
ultimate standard
that transcends us and I'm deeply
skeptical that that would happen
[Music]
you